c'est sur ce petit territoire au statut
unique en chine que pékin voudrait
renforcer son autorité
le gouvernement chinois a adopté ce
jeudi une loi qui vise à combattre le
terrorisme
la sécession la subversion ainsi que les
ingérences étrangères
une initiative en réponse mois de
manifestations tout au long de l'année
donnant lieu parfois des face-à-face
avec la police
pour le secrétaire d'état américain mike
pompéo c'est une atteinte grave au
principe un pays deux systèmes qui
régissent sur le territoire semi
autonome aujourd'hui j'ai signalé au
congrès que hong kong plus autonome par
rapport à la chine compte tenu des faits
sur le terrain
les etats unis sont aux côtés du peuple
de hong kong
une déclaration qui ouvre la voie à de
nouvelles sanctions
washington pourrait suspendre le statut
préférentiel de hong kong et venir ainsi
alimenter la contestation
la figure de proue du mouvement de
protestation joshua wang encourage
donald trump a renforcé les mesures
économiques contre la chine
nous exhortons le président trump à
faire écho à la recommandation du
secrétaire d'état
mag son pays de renforcer les sanctions
économiques partiel sur la capitale
financière de hong kong
cela vaut également pour les hommes
d'affaires où les politiciens qui
violent les droits de l'homme en
améliorant la loi sur la sécurité
nationale qui érode l'avenir de hong
kong
une décision jugée barbares
déraisonnable et la plus éhontée
selon le bureau du commissaire du
ministère des affaires étrangères de
hong kong
le congrès américain est également venu
attaquer sur un nouveau front la
deuxième puissance économique mondiale
persée qu'une proposition de loi a été
adopté mercredi pour sanctionner des
responsables chinois accusés de
l'internement deux masses de huy bourg
et nous sommes dans cette chambre
aujourd'hui dans notre chambre des
représentants sur une base bipartisane
très forte
nous envoyons aux persécutés un message
pour leur dire qu'ils ne sont pas
oubliés nous disons au président chinois
vous pouvez dire à ces gens qu'ils sont
oubliés mais ils ne le sont pas et nous
sommes dans cette chambre des
représentants pour y veiller à travers
une législation bipartisane bicaméral
nous sommes ici pour soutenir
mire le projet de loi sur les droits
humains des ouigours une législation les
partisanes fortes pour lutter en faveur
des droits et de la dignité du peuple
ouïghour face à l'oppression chinoise
un vote qui risque d'envenimer davantage
les relations déjà tendues entre les
deux puissances
reste à savoir si donald trump
promulguera cette loi si le texte est
signé ils risquent de provoquer la
colère de la chine qui nie toute
atteinte aux droits humains et tout
internement de masse de membres de cette
population turcophone et musulmane
habitants dans la province du sindh
chang
[Musique]